Pass ja auf, dass du es nicht fallen lässt!
ja
Die andere Person weiß etwas bereits.
Ich hätte gern eine
Schachtel Dromedar Zigaretten.
Gerne, Sie kaufen ja jeden Tag eine.
Musst du heute nicht arbeiten?
Nein. Ich habe dir ja gestern
gesagt, dass ich heute nicht arbeiten muss.
Wir haben bei unserem letzten Meeting
ja besprochen, wie wir vorgehen wollen.
Habt ihr eure Arbeiten erledigt?
Ich habe euch jaeine Mail geschrieben.
Wann kommt Papa nach Hause?
Erst morgen. Er arbeitet heute ja in Salzburg.
Man ist über eine Situation
besonders (positiv oder negativ) überrascht.
Wir sind ja ganz alleine am Strand.
Das Essen sieht ja lecker aus.
Ihr habt ja einen riesigen Garten.
Diese Übertragungfunktioniert ja sehr schlecht.
Im Imperativverstärkt “ja” die Aussage.
Wehren Sie sich ja nicht!
Mach ja nie mehr so eine Unordnung!
Kommen Sie ja nicht ohne Maskeund Schutzausrüstung in den Raum!
Fahrt ja vorsichtig Kinder!
doch
Erklärung:
“Doch” zeigt eine Überraschung an. Man
ist überrascht, dass die andere Personetwas nicht weiß.
Sie wissen doch, dass ich immer nur Kaffee trinke!
Ich habe doch gesagt, dass du aufpassen sollst!
Sie haben doch ein Paket bestellt.
Es ist doch nicht meine Schuld,
wenn das Schiff später anlegt.
Im Imperativ macht
“doch” den Satz freundlicher.
Beobachten Sie doch den Stern dort!
Trinken Sie doch einen Cocktail!
Wie komme ich zum Kino?
Nimm doch den Bus!
Probieren Sie das Kleid doch mal an!
denn
"Denn” benutzt man in Fragen.
Wie schmeckt euch denn das Essen?
Suchen Sie denn eine Marketingfachfrau?
Hier sehen wir einen kleinen Stachelkaktus.
Gibt es denn auch einen grossen Stachelkaktus?
Haben Sie denn Schmerzen?
halt & eben
“Halt & eben” benutzt man, wennetwas nicht zu ändern ist, oft auch in Klischees.
Hier muss ich halt warten.
Hier muss ich eben warten.
Das Flugzeug ist halt verspätet.
Das Flugzeug ist eben verspätet.
Chinesisches Essen schmeckt halt sehr gut!
Chinesisches Essen schmeckt eben sehr gut!
Ich muss halt den Schnee wegräumen.
Ich muss eben den Schnee wegräumen.
eh
Man ist sicher, dass etwas so passieren wird.
Das ist einfach. Das versteht ihr eh!
Mit Yoga werde ich eh abnehmen.
Die Situation hat sich geändert,
jetzt funktioniert etwas nicht mehr.
Ich gehe jetzt rein.
Es beginnt eh zu regnen.
Die andere Mannschaft
hat schon drei Tore geschossen.
Jetzt gewinnen wir eh nicht.